israel has become the first country to
announce a second
national lockdown to combat the
coronavirus this comes after a surge in
new infections prime minister benjamin
netanyahu said the new lockdown will
begin on friday
and last for three weeks
as israel's outbreak threatened to race
out of control
benjamin netanyahu announced the
unpopular but perhaps
unavoidable decision today we decided on
a strict lockdown plan for three weeks
with an option to extend
but as of now we've decided that the
lockdown will last until the end of the
holiday
health ministry executives and hospital
managers
have warned us that death rates are
forcing the application of immediate
measures
a part of the medical staff and the
hospitals are overwhelmed
[Music]
israel has one of the highest per capita
infection rates in the world
over 1100 people have died for days
israelis have been protesting to demand
that nyahu stepped down for alleged
corruption
and for bundling the response to the
covet-19 crisis
after the lockdown announcement on
sunday demonstrators blocked roads at
israel's ben gurion airport
where netanyahu was due to fly to the
u.s to sign a peace deal to normalize
ties with bahrain
we have a corrupt prime minister who's
been charged with bribery
who refuses to go to court and instead
is going to the united states to divert
our attention
as if there's some magic peace agreement
instead of staying here it's undermining
the entire
democracy they didn't do their job the
economy is in a catastrophe
and they want to put us
[Music]
netanyahu will fly back to israel after
formally signing the agreement with
bahrain on tuesday
when he returns the crisis will be
waiting for him
let's get more on this now with our
correspondent tanya kramer in
jerusalem good day to you tanya with
coronavirus cases hitting a new high in
israel how have people been reacting to
the latest
lockdown announcement
i think people have been prepared for
this in a way the outline of this had
been decided last week
but they only knew you know how long
it's going to be from
last night's press conference by prime
minister benjamin netanyahu but they had
hoped that it will
work out differently i mean there's a
sense here that for a long time there
has been no government strategy
as to how to deal with this crisis and
of course it will hit
hard of businesses people who might
you know be put on a temporary leave
again and
the economy has not really become better
since the last lockdown and of course
it's also period now of the high
holidays
starting with the jewish new year the
lockdown is supposed to start on
friday on the eve of rosh hashanah the
jewish new year
and this is usually a period where
people are coming together where
families visiting each other
they haven't been really able to travel
much over the past months so all of this
together
makes it a very difficult time but also
because there's the big question what
will happen
after the lockdown people know now this
is supposed to last for three weeks
possibly even longer but then
what will happen afterwards that's the
big question now israel was one of the
first countries
in the world to implement strict
measures back in in march what's behind
the new rise in cases
well this has been discussed here a lot
as well
as you said it looked quite fine after
the first lockdown
in in may and then the economy was
opened up quite
quickly and even the prime minister
benjamin netanyahu has acknowledged that
was maybe
a bit too fast at the time but there was
a lot of concern
over the economic fallout but of course
then there was a sense that for a long
time this coalition government
has not been doing enough at least
there's the sense of the public here
you know to put in place a real strategy
like track and tracing
uh didn't really work they only put in
place
last week nighttime curfews in
communities with high infection rates
that's the only thing they could have
they could agree on but with an
infection rate that by the end of last
week was four thousand
uh cases daily of new corona infections
the government had to decide now to um
to implement a new lockdown and tanya
thank you very much for that
from jerusalem
let's get you up to date now with some
of the latest developments in the
pandemic the world health
organizations reported a record one day
rise in cases of the
virus globally just under 308
000 positive cases were reported in the
previous 24 hours
south korea's reported its lowest amount
of daily cases in about a month the
country has now begun
easing its tough social distancing rules
and
u.s president donald trump has held his
first fully indoor
rally in monster event outraged nevada
state
officials who warned it violated
restrictions on crowd sizes
you